destiny become legends trailer i like i
like the customization like that we're
seeing a little bit of like character
customization like the I coming piece
written on the rifle with like all the
extra like all the hash marks of pills
and hopefully we'll actually see that
kind of depth to the game it remains to
be seen we didn't really get a taste of
that in the beta although there was some
other armor customization that was
locked on some equipment but it was it
was indicated that it was there this
mission also takes place on the moon
which was the two-hour timed exclusive
we saw in the beta yeah I did not get to
play that but United because it was at
noon on a saturday on the last day of
the beta when most human beings are not
sitting around playing video games and
so this is a bit of a live-action
recreation of that this part on the moon
specifically directed by joseph kosinski
the guy who did ab living in tron legacy
although i will call you out Joseph
there's a section in here where a dude
like unnecessarily racks his shotgun and
expels around to make a point just like
one of the worst shooter movie tropes
and every single show or movie there's
nothing I hate more than an alien with
no respect for history we definitely see
all the the Guardians doing their supers
which are the same supers that every saw
in the beta yeah although oddly enough
the hunters super isn't as expressive in
this trailer as the others are fiery
golden gun isn't here it is cool though
like they do show Venus so anybody who
may be went and checked out there Google
Maps view of Venus and Mars and the moon
got a small preview of what they're
gonna do so you know again like a lot of
the stuff we're seeing in this live
action trailer our stuff from level 1
through 8 so we've yet to see the higher
level guardian powers being an MMO I
guess they're starting you off a little
bit weak in your powers or at least you
know they're not letting you see the
really unique stuff early on right and
so I'm really curious what we'll end up
seeing and the game did imply that there
was a significant change to class at 15
as well overall impressions of this game
so far and like after watching this
trailer I'm definitely tempering my
expectations seems like a good game
I'm I want to try and separate though
some of the height that's happening this
week this trailer is kind of cool it's
live action you know we've all played
through the beta we're going to see on
monday when we do our live stream if
this game has a lot more to offer or if
we've seen most it from the beta um i
say if we can't see what we want to see
in a 12 hour epic live stream then I
don't know what we're missing yeah
hopefully not all the game yeah so those
are some of our impressions of the
trailer which looks kind of cool we have
it in its entirety on our site but it's
also airing tonight during the Seahawks
green bay packers game first NFL game of
the season so people are gonna get a 90
second version of that inferior to what
is on gamespot knock knock who's there